les innovations dans l'europe de l'est
après la pologne et la république
tchèque s'est maintenant l'allemagne qui
menace et un embouteillage monstre à
lyon pour l'inauguration très
controversée d'un périphérique à péage
le bras de fer entre l'europe et les
états unis sur la fusion de boeing et de
mcdonnell douglas la réforme de la
politique agricole commune le tour de
france est la grosse fatigue du danois
bjarne riis et enfin les suites
politiques du plan de redressement
annoncé hier par le gouvernement
edouard balladur sera notre invité dans
ce journal
voilà monsieur bonsoir après la pologne
l'autriche et la république tchèque les
inondations menacent maintenant
l'allemagne 115 personnes ont déjà
trouvé la mort dans cette crue du siècle
cent quarante mille autres ont dû être
déplacées ce soir lauder continue de
faire des siennes en et en éclatant en
égalant son record historique de 1930 un
premier village en allemagne a dû être
évacué sous la menace d'une rupture de
digue et à francfort sous l'eau d'heure
où il s'est rendu
helmut kohl a jugé la situation critique
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux sur
place
thierry kurt et et pierre emmanuel
luneau attendre et voir
telle est la situation mais d'autres ne
pouvaient pas se permettre de patienter
marek est ce que l'on appelle ici en
pologne un homme d'affaires sa maison
son night club est un peu éloigné de
secours beach et il n'était donc pas
prévu de le protéger
il a donc construit surtout payé tout
seul sa digue
300 mètres de long six mètres de haut il
a dû vendre de voitures pour cela payer
arabes 80 seule personne n'est venu me
demander ça va est ce que ça marche
c'est une bande de vauriens avec mon
voisin ça m'a coûté 120 milles deutsch
mark 400 mille francs et on a fait ça en
deux jours la digue elle commence un peu
plus loin
ici on a en mémoire les images terribles
des villes du sud du pays ravagé
parce qu'elles n'ont pas su se protéger
mais après trois jours et trois nuits
d'efforts on apprécie enfin beaucoup
plus tranquillement
le soleil revenu à l'abri d'une digue
maintenant beaucoup plus sûres demain on
attend encore beaucoup d'eau donc on va
attendre toute la nuit et toute la
journée pour voir il faut attendre
pour patienter ils ont pu observer les
allemands terminé leur propre digue sur
l'autre rive de l'eau d'heure on a
commencé beaucoup plus tard francfort
est situé trois mètres plus haut que ce
to bi tché
on a longtemps pensé que cela suffirait
à protéger la ville mais la deuxième que
arrive alors que la première vague s'est
étalée du louvre a encore monté mais bon
j'ai l'impression qu'elles vont tenir
hellmuth pour les venu constater les
efforts entrepris et surtout les moyens
mis en place pour une improbable
l'évacuation de la ville 90 mille
habitants une visite éclaire la
situation allemande et sans aucune
mesure avec les situations tchèques et
polonaises à l'est lauder a tué plus de
100 personnes est noyé un demi million
d'hectares
ici la leçon a porté on a voulu prendre
aucun risque
en pologne le parlement devra examiner
une motion pour demander au président
d'instaurer l'état d'urgence dans toutes
les régions touchées par les inondations
ce soir la fondation de france ouvre un
compte d'urgence pour venir en aide à
ces populations vous pouvez adresser vos
dons à la fondation de france pologne
boîtes postales 22,75 362 paris cedex 08
la révolte des maires du vercors 12 élus
du canton de pont-en-royans ont
démissionné pour protester contre un
arrêté préfectoral
cet arrêté interdit purement et
simplement l'accès à plusieurs rivières
exploitée par edf
il intervient au lendemain du jugement
dans la sphère du drac cette tragédie au
cours de laquelle six et aux écoliers et
leurs accompagnatrices et est mort
emporté par les eaux de la rivière
joseph dans la pierre
comment interdire à ses enfants de jouer
dans les eaux fraîches de la bourne
c'est pourtant ce que vient de décider
le préfet de l'isère pour des raisons de
sécurité un ouvrage gdf se trouve en
amour et ces baigneurs ne sont pas à
l'abri d'un lâcher d'eau intempestifs
mais dans ces gorges où l'on vit du
tourisme cette décision soulève la
colère des élus mais arrêtez beaucoup
trop simpliste beaucoup beaucoup trop
autoritaire en interdisant le site toute
l'année de façon aveugle
donc c'est une applicable à partir
moment c'est inapplicable non en tant
que maire on est obligé de donner
d'autres démissions nous n'avons pas été
consultés vise les 12 maires de l'isère
qui viennent de démissionner de leur
côté les responsables de campings et les
commerçants parlent d'un arrêt de mort
pour la région nous on vit beaucoup par
rapport à ça faut pas croire la bourn
c'est quelque chose de grandiose aussi
bien du point de vue de la pêche que
pour n'importe quoi pour les baigneurs
le camping ainsi de suite
ça représente énormément mais le préfet
a décidé d'appliquer le règlement entré
en vigueur depuis la mort de six enfants
et de leurs accompagnatrices en décembre
95 au bord du drac l'enfant bleu des
rivières du département a été soumis à
un test d'évaluation
sept d'entre elles ont été jugées à haut
risque le préfet en interdit l'accès
aujourd'hui quand par l'analyse conclut
convergentes de l'exploitant de ces
aménagements hydrauliques et des
services de l'état services techniques
qui en assure la tutelle quand ces
trente ouvrages sont affectées d'un
risque mortel le préfet ne peut pas non
plus rester sans rien faire face à la
protestation des maires du département
le préfet vient de décider d'organiser
une réunion de concertation fixée au 30
juillet prochain à nice une association
tente d'alerter les pouvoirs publics sur
l'importance de la pollution en
méditerranée pour en faire la
démonstration
les plongeurs remonte du fond de l'eau
tous les déchets qu'ils peuvent trouver
vous allez voir la pêche et parfois
miraculeuses yasmina farber et didier
beaumont à 200 mètres des plages de la
croisette cinq plongeurs vont tenter un
étrange record du monde
blanc va effectivement trouvé une zone 2
un peu près 2000 m² tranquille de le
situer comme d'habitude ce sont les
courants marins
en fait ils stabilisent season
dépollution toujours sur les mêmes sites
et c'est assez scandaleux vous aideront
à passer absolument affolants top de
papilles en ce record va durer combien
de temps alors les cinq plongeurs avons
effectué une plongée pendant une heure
ils vont ramasser tous les détritus qui
vont rencontrer sur le forme pour les
remonter aux bateaux et après nous
pourrons l'inventaire de tous ces
détritus à 10 mètres de profondeur des
déchets en tout genre se sont accumulés
des détritus symbolique souvent
ordinaires boîtes de boisson plastique
souvenir de feu d'artifice des déchets
parfois plus anecdotiques comme du
mobilier urbain
les plongeurs vont remonter à la surface
et épaves de terriens sans scrupules
convives à toi quand même on vit là en
âge là on navigue là sur les bateaux est
vrai que ça reste ça reste ça devienne
propre
après une heure de plongée retour sur la
terre ferme
la pêche a été bonne les touristes
restent médusés pendant le long
descriptif de lui s'il inventaire des
objets retiré lors du procès verbal
relaxe plastique une deux trois quatre
cinq six petites chaises d'extérieur
l'état est responsable de la propreté
des fonds marins mais les autorités
précisent qu'elles interviennent en cas
de pollution dangereuse à venir
méditerranée tente de mettre au point un
navire pour draguer les zones touchées
en attendant nos épaves contemporaine
vestiges de nos modes de vie continue de
hanter les fonds marins est toujours en
méditerranée la collision qui a eu lieu
hier soir entre de hors bord au large de
cannes une collision cours de laquelle
un néerlandais d'une vingtaine d'années
a été tué eh bien elle serait due pour
l'essentiel à l'inconscience totale du
pilote dans lequel se trouvait la
victime c'est ce que dit ce soir le
directeur des affaires maritimes pour
les alpes maritimes on n'avait pas vu
une pareille baghai pagaille depuis bien
longtemps à lyon paradoxe il s'agissait
justement de tester un nouveau tronçon
du périphérique nord une autoroute qui
est gratuite pour l'instant mais qui ne
le restera pas bien longtemps ce qui a
provoqué bien sûr la colère de bon
nombre de lui y note de lyonnais
d'autant que pour son édification la
route
elle a été réduite didier guyot et
olivier jacquelin selon les concepteurs
du périphérique nord ce mardi devait
tête historique les lyonnais allaient
enfin tester avec joie l'axé routier qui
allaient désengorger leur ville en fait
ce fait une journée noire embouteillages
longues files d'attentes en plein coeur
de l'été on craint le pire pour la
rentrée le périphérique nord long de 10
km propose de relier l'ouest et l'est
sans passer par le centre ville grâce à
un viaduc à deux tunnels
coût de l'opération 6 milliards de
francs financé en grande partie par les
collectivités locales
les premières déconvenues le
périphérique un péage
il ya deux choses qui sont importantes
d'abord c'est que ces travaux ont été
financés par d'importants fonds publics
car sur + 6 milliards de travaux il y en
a plus de la moitié qui ont été payés
par le contribuable
et la deuxième chose qui me gêne c'est
la mise en place d'un péage qui va
permettre un super profits aux sociétés
comme boeing et dumez puisque sur 30
milliards de recettes sur 35 ans il y en
a 14 milliards qui vont être distribués
en dividende
prix du péage de trois fois en or plein
lourd pour le porte monnaie
mais là où la colère gronde plus encore
c'est que tout est fait pour pousser les
automobilistes vers ce péage l'ancien
voirie qui desservait le centre-ville
est réduite de moitié
une souricière pour les 80 mille
véhicules jour qui passe par ici
une souricière prévu dans le contrat
signé entre l'ancienne municipalité de
michel noir et la société bouygues
selon raymond barre dénoncer ce contrat
coûterait très cher long ou ne dénonce
pas un contrat de concession qui est
fait pour 30 ans sans alors se mettre
dans la situation de ceux qui ont à
payer 2 adam n'y fait or je sais que
pour payer les indemnités il faudrait
prélever des infos sur les contribuables
lyonnais
par conséquent je sais par tous les
moyens de leur éviter cela les opposants
aux périphériques affirment que la
liberté d'aller et venir est ici bafouer
un recours a été déposé devant les
tribunaux contre le rétrécissement de
l'ancien voirie et contre le péage les
magistrats devrait statuer en septembre
renault vilvorde 92 % des ouvriers ont
accepté le plan social le vote a eu lieu
toute la journée moins qu'une adhésion à
un plan c'est surtout pour les ouvriers
la volonté d'en finir avec l'incertitude
à vilvorde sébastien guibert et
dominique merlet
le vote a eu lieu à bulletins secrets
mais le résultat était pratiquement
connu davance les deux mille six cents
ouvriers appelés à voter pour ou contre
le plan social n'avait guère le choix
la direction de renault belgique les
avait prévenus ce plan était le dernier
à prendre ou à laisser
rares sont ceux qui s'y sont opposés
c'était pour la réouverture de l'usiné
renault
maintenant je peux pas accepter cette
loi sociale de toute façon nous ne
paiera jamais assez ce qui nous a offert
à 16 heures c'est le dépouillement tous
les ouvriers ne sont pas venus voter
mais le résultat des urnes est sans
appel
92 % approuvent le plan 167 ils sont
pendants corps qui sont d'accord 1988
merci le choix qu'ils ont des serres
séparés soient correctes c'est un choix
dans la misère alors c'est vrai ce qui à
dessein jour si tu dois choisir il perd
de toute façon certains ont profité de
la journée pour régler quelques détails
administratifs de leur préretraite leur
reclassement ou leur départ quant au
5300 voiture que les ouvriers appel
depuis février leur trésor de guerre
elles seront rendues vendredi à la
direction les ouvriers savait qu'en cas
de rejet du plan social il n'aurait eu
d'autre recours que d'entamer à nouveau
des actions d'éclat en belgique comme en
france après cinq mois d'incertitude
il n'en avait plus le courage vilvorde
va donc bel et bien fermé définitivement
ses par lassitude que les ouvriers s'y
sont résolus aujourd'hui le bras de fer
entre l'europe et les états unis sur la
fusion des deux constructeurs
aéronautiques boeing et mcdonnell
douglas le président américain bill
clinton est intervenu personnellement
pour mettre en garde l'europe contre un
éventuel veto de sa part à cette fusion
la sphère aux états unis fait grand
bruit à washington philippe gassot à
washington ont fait souffler le chaud et
le froid
plus de 100 élus du congrès ont adressé
par lettre un avertissement aux
européens il souligne que la position du
vieux continent sur la fusion mcdonnell
boeing aura un effet sensible sur les
relations transatlantiques
les élus du congrès qualifie d'
inacceptable la position de bruxelles et
mettent en avant ce sur quoi
non jamais transigé leur sécurité
nationale
le porte-parole de la maison-blanche
montent aussi au créneau et pousse
l'europe a dit il prendre la bonne
décision
le président clinton qui jusqu'ici a été
le seul à donner la réaction officielle
américaine promet en cas d'échec la
guerre économique
il a lui aussi ses dernières heures
utiliser pleinement son téléphone il
aurait même contacté un de ses
homologues européens les américains sont
prêts à toute éventualité même s'ils
espèrent que leur dernière offre
éviteront le choc frontal et si ça n'est
pas le cas des mesures de rétorsion
commerciale pourrait être prise dès
américains
d'ordinaire prolixe devant les médias ne
parlent pas mais on sait qu'il pourrait
s'appuyer sur la section 301 de la loi
qui leur permettrait par exemple de
limiter les échanges aérien entre
l'europe et les états unis et ce pour
commencer et ce soir les américains
ferait quand même de nouvelles
propositions s'engageant notamment à
supprimer tous leurs contrats
d'exclusivité notamment avec les
compagnies aériennes
l'europe toujours et les critères de
maastricht au lendemain de l'annoncé du
plan de redressement du gouvernement le
président en exercice de l'union
européenne le premier ministre
luxembourgeois été reçus tour à tour par
jacques chirac et lionel jospin
le critère des 3% de déficit n'est pas
une condition sinequanone at il dit tout
dépendra de l'appréciation globale des
différents gouvernements
il faut dire que tous les candidats
l'euro ne sont pas au même niveau quant
au respect de ces fameux quatre critères
de maastricht
au jour d'aujourd'hui deux pays
seulement sur les 15 européen
remplissent ces fameuses conditions
thibault de barbeyrac et le rond b
mesures annoncées hier par dominique
strauss kahn vis da réduire les déficits
publics
selon maastricht ses déficits ne doivent
pas excéder 3% du pib c'est à dire de la
richesse nationale
en l'état la france n'obtiendrait pas le
feu vert de bruxelles pour adhérer à la
monnaie unique mais les critères ça peut
aussi s'interpréter souplement
évident d'après une lecture paraître des
traités avec 3 0 n'est pas une condition
sine qua none l'autre critère
déterminant celui du poids de la dette
accumulée au fil des ans ne poserait pas
de problème la france est endettée à
hauteur de 56 % du pib
c'est inférieur aux 60% requis scénario
inverse aux pays bas à 2 4% les déficits
sont peu élevés mais si rien n'est fait
pour diminuer la dette
les hollandais risque de rater le
premier train de l'euro en allemagne les
déficits comme la dette sont supérieures
au seuil fixé par le traité
mais bonne qui entend être une des
locomotives de la monnaie unique affirme
qu'elle sera à l'heure au rendez vous
l'espagne aussi en est convaincu et
pourtant les signaux sont plus
inquiétants 20,96 le déficit atteignait
plus de 4% du pib et la dette près de
70% madrid a engagé un vaste plan de
réduction des dépenses
l'italie c'est pour l'instant le mauvais
élève pour participer à l'euro elle
devrait réduire de moitié et ses
déficits et sa dette publique pour
tenter d'y parvenir un impôt spécial a
même été créé cette année pour londres
le problème est différent les comptes du
royaume uni sont bons mais la livre
sterling a quitté le système monétaire
européen en 92 conditions disqualifiante
pour l'euro feu vert en revanche quasi
certain pour le luxembourg et la
finlande les deux seuls pays à respecter
d'ores et déjà les critères alors
edouard balladur bonsoir vous êtes en
direct près de chamonix
j'espère qu'il fait beau dans les alpes
trèbes autres alors on l'a vu avec cette
appréciation du président en exercice de
l'union européenne tout le monde a l'air
à peu près satisfait aujourd'hui du plan
de redressement annoncé hier par le par
le gouvernement tout le monde je dirais
et y compris les allemands et le plan de
ce que vous appelez le plan de
redressement annoncé hier en fait n'est
pas un plan de redressement à long terme
c'est une addition de mesures à court
terme
quel est le problème de la france il
faut en revenir là finalement parce que
c'est l'essentiel
il est son intérêt d'entrer dans la
monnaie européenne pour préserver son
activité son emploi et il est donc de
son intérêt de réduire les déficits
publics
or ces déficits sont encore trop élevés
je passe sur l'audit le bilan du passé
il était très élevé il y a quatre ans au
bout de quatre années ils sont beaucoup
moins élevés mais il reste encore une
partie du chemin à faire alors c'est sûr
le dit monsieur balladur ça devienne
quand la mosson cet audit vous l'avez
trouvé comment cet audit on je les
trouvais à ses objectifs
ils ont été le cas par le passé je dise
à part ça hop du tout écouter le les
audits qui ont été fait précédemment
notamment celui que j'avais demandé il
ya quatre ans était parfaitement aux
objectifs
qu'est-ce qu'il fait apparaître cet
audit il fait apparaître qu'il y a
quatre ans il y avait plus de 450
milliards de déficit et qu'aujourd'hui
il y en a moins de 300 je le répète
c'est encore trop mais beaucoup a été
fait alors comment faut-il le faire
comment doit-on réduire les déficits
pour que nous retrouvions l'emploi une
chose d'abord dans tous les français
doivent être bien convaincu il n'y a pas
assez de travail pour tous les français
il y a trop de chômage et pourquoi parce
que nous avons trop de dépenses
publiques est trop d'impôts nous
réussissons cette performance d'être
l'un des pays au monde où le chômage est
le plus important et où les déficits et
des impôts sont les plus importants
alors comment comment réduit alors ça
veut dire quoi
actuellement par le gouvernement est un
bon chemin après vous écoutez je pense
que le chemin qui est prix ne fait pas
une part suffisante aux baisses de
dépenses
je suis convaincu que si nous voulons
retrouver l'emploi pour tous il nous
faut baisser des dépenses et baisser les
impôts or ce que je constate c'est qu'on
baisse peu les dépenses on les a
d'ailleurs augmenté la semaine dernière
à peu près autant sinon même plus et que
l'on augmente les impôts
eh bien je dis que si l'on prend cette
voie
l'on ne résoudra pas le problème alors
lorsque je vous disais tout à l'heure il
s'agit de mesures à court terme
la vérité c'est que nous verrons tout
cela au moment du budget de 80 18 c'est
à dire dans deux mois mais dans deux
mois justement nous verrons si le
gouvernement prend la mesure des efforts
que doivent faire les français et la
france et s'il s'oriente vers la baisse
des dépenses ouvert la hausse des impôts
c'est un choix fondamental pour l'avenir
du travail de l'emploi en france alors à
votre avis est ce qu'une seule baisse
des dépenses peuvent suffire et je dirai
comment dans la mesure on l'a vu avec le
passé un gouvernement l'option avait
plutôt été d'augmenter les impôts et
cette fois pour les ménages pas pour les
entreprises
à écouter je voudrais quand même vous
dire quelque chose c'est que depuis
quatre ans je le répète pour la
troisième fois depuis quatre ans nous
avons réduit de 200 milliards environ
150 à 200 milliards les déficits publics
alors qu'elle dépense faut-il diminuer
mais pour commencer il faut pas les
augmenter et lorsque j'entends les
déclarations des uns et des autres
visant à recruter un nombre nouveau de
fonctionnaires je dis faisons attention
depuis 20 ans qu'est ce qui s'est passé
en france on n'a pratiquement pas créé
d'emplois dans le secteur concurrentiel
ce qu'on appelle le secteur marchand
l'industrie le commerce les services et
les emplois qui ont été créés ont été
pour l'essentiel créés dans le secteur
public c'est à dire financés par l'impôt
et le résultat quel est il
c'est que nous avons le taux d'impôt le
plus important de toute l'union
européenne
autrement dit l'annoncé 350 mille
emplois à la fois dans le privé les 350
milles en public ça continue à ne pas
offrir votre agrément des six est
financé par dell des augmentations
d'impôts non je crois que ce n'est pas
la solution la solution c'est de réduire
les dépenses et de réduire les impôts et
nous verrons dans deux mois si le
gouvernement prend justement la mesure
des de ce qu'il faut faire pour l'avenir
leur journée d'hier quelque chose c'est
que finalement le problème fondamental
de la france qu'elle est il s'est pas 3%
de critères de maastricht et pas tel
pourcentage d'impôts de déficit ou de
dépenses le problème fondamental c'est
qu'il y a trop de chômage en france et
qu'il n'y a pas assez de travail pour
tous voilà notre problème et notamment
pour les jeunes
alors depuis vingt ans la situation
s'est considérablement dégradée en 20
ans que faut-il faire pour l'avenir
et bien moi je dis que nous ne pouvons
pas nous français prétendre avoir raison
contre tout le reste du monde partout
dans le monde on abaisse les dépenses et
on abaisse les impôts et on a une
croissance meilleure que la nôtre et on
a un an
fois meilleur que le nôtre il faut
raison contre tout le monde
ils fondent il faut donc baisser les
dépenses je reviens quand j'entre pour
s'envoyer de ses pas fondamental pour
toi on ne parle que de ça depuis
craindre à mal de temps ida mental je
dire que ce soit 2,8 ou 3,2 c pas
fondamental il faut s'assurer que le
gouvernement dise et qu'ils s'engagent
et pour 98 à ces fameux 3%
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand même pour
vous mais absolument c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais je dis que tout dépend de
la façon dont on va y arriver
et monsieur en augmentant les impôts ce
ne sera pas une bonne nouvelle en fait
alors à terre neuve à détruire à
l'emploi dans notre pays et aggraverait
le chômage
et est-ce qu'il faut renoncer à certains
avantages fiscaux comme par exemple et
les aides des emplois domicile stella
vous avez vous aviez remonter le plafond
de cdf quand vous étiez au gouvernement
écoutez ce que je vais vous dire je ne
peux pas entrer dans le cadre d'un
entretien de quelques minutes dans le
détail des choses on en reparlera
peut-être lors du budget 98 que je veux
vous dire c'est que on ne peut plus
augmenter les impôts et les cotisations
en france on ne peut plus s'en sauf à
prendre des risques très graves pour
l'avenir et notamment pour l'avenir de
la jeunesse
il faut réduire les dépenses vous me
disiez tout à l'heure quelles dépenses
par exemple il y à 450 milliards
d'interventions publiques c'est le tiers
du budget ou presque le tiers personne
ne croit qu'il ya pas matière à
économies dans ce domaine par exemple ne
pas créer de nouveaux postes de
fonctionnaires qui ne font qu'aggraver
la situation je donne ces deux exemples
je pourrais en donner d'autres c'est une
question de volonté des pays ont fait
cet effort et même des pays socialistes
comme les pays bas qui sont aujourd'hui
dans une meilleure situation que la
nôtre où le danemark bien pourquoi nous
français serions nous incapables de
réduire nos dépenses publiques serions
nous condamner augmenté perpétuellement
les impôts c'est une situation qui à
terme n'est pas tenable alors attends le
gouvernement vient d'arriver sur le mois
et demi il ya un mois et demi seulement
justement monsieur balladur parce que
comme vous le disiez le temps nous est
compté
un tout petit mot simplement
d'appréciation sur cette méthode du
gouvernement et cette méthode de
monsieur jospin mais comment la
qualifierait vous cette méthode
c'est la question je vous pose écoutez
cette méthode n'a rien de particulier je
ne vois rien qui mérite d'être relevée
dans ce qui a été fait je disais à
l'instant le gouvernement vient
d'arriver il est là depuis un mois et
demi
laissons lui le temps jusqu'au mois de
septembre d'élaborer son budget mais si
son budget couvre 98 tu dois prendre le
même chemin que celui qu'on prend depuis
hier c'était dire augmenter les impôts
et ne pas réduire les dépenses je dis et
je répète que nous ne résoudront pas le
problème fondamental de la france qui
est de donner du travail pour tous alors
que la france est celui des grands pays
où il ya le taux de chômage le plus
important merci à la l'enjeu merci vous
compte comme ceux balladur d'avoir
accepté notre notre invitation et ce
soir et bonnes vacances visiblement à ce
magnifique
la cote de popularité de jacques chirac
est à la hausse de 8 points selon le
dernier sondage bva à paris match un
sondage réalisé après l'intervention du
14 juillet le chef de l'état totalisent
48 % de bonnes opinions quant à lionel
jospin 52% des personnes lui font
confiance
la poste devrait embaucher 5000 jeunes
d'ici un an
jean louis guigou l'époux du ministre de
la justice sera nommé demain à la tête
de la date à la dir est de la délégation
à l'aménagement du territoire et puis
sachez enfin que dans l' enquête sur les
fraudes électorales présumées dans la
circonscription de jean tibéri à paris
les gendarmes ont saisi que
l'intégralité des fameuses listes la
réforme de la pac autrement dit la
politique agricole commune les ministres
de l'agriculture des quinze sont réunis
à bruxelles la commission doit leur
présenter sa réforme de la pac pour l'an
2000 une réforme qui prévoit une baisse
des prix vous le savez les prix fixés
par bruxelles vous avez quand même des
compensations jean yves perrin et
vincent maillard se sont donc rendus
chez un exploitant agricole en normandie
c'est un producteur de lait or selon la
réforme de la pac les prix garanti aux
producteurs de lait devraient baisser de
10%
une perspective peu réjouissante même si
pour la première fois aussi une prime
laitière de compensation est instituée
des normandes qui broutent
consciencieusement sous les pommiers pas
de doute nous sommes bien en normandie
au coeur du plus grand bassin laitier de
france jean luc duval y a pris la suite
de son père en 88 avec une quarantaine
de vaches un quota laitier annuel de 200
mille litres
ils estiment s'en sortir convenablement
alors la future réforme qui prévoit une
baisse du prix du lait de 10 % à partir
de l'an 2000 salles de l enthousiasme
guerre et la prime à la vache laitière
qui sera créée pour compenser cette
baisse ne suffira pas toute baisse de
son chiffre d'affaires due à la baisse
des prix d'intervention est belle de
compensation se traduira par une baisse
de mon revenu donc un revenu de 80 à 100
mille balles
quel sens 400 mille francs si on a une
baisse entre 30 et 40 mille francs bon
on voit que ça fait aux alentours de 30
à 40% de de baisse de revenus dans ce
calcul
ce qui pèse le plus c'est la suppression
prévue de la prime pour le maïs fourrage
et produits pour nourrir les vaches
l'hiver elle lui rapporte 30 mille
francs par an fruit paradoxale de la
première réforme de la politique
agricole commune
en 92 pour continuer de toucher des
primes
jean lui pourra en l'an 2000 remplacer
le maïs fourrager part du blé et
retrouver ainsi ses 30000 francs annuels
en fait c'est le principe même de cette
future réforme que jean-luc compte est
bon à la chanson au niveau des
producteurs de lait
détraigne en grande partie par le
consommateur par le bruit de l'est que
l'on vend à de france qui vous fait
essentiellement notre venue avec la
proposition que peut nous faire la
commission
là on verrait notre revenu en grande
partie fait part des aides européennes
l'ombre payé par de l'argent public donc
d'origine du contribuable avec la
curieuse impression d'être encore un peu
plus assister et ça les producteurs de
lait même pas du tout
le robot fait son entrée à l'hôpital en
france plus précisément à montpellier au
chu lapeyronie ou depuis 16 mois un
robot made in usa parcourt les couloirs
programmé pour secondes et le personnel
soignant dans ses tâches les plus
répétitives jo et ses surnoms sera
exploité jusqu'en décembre karine
comazzi et pascal course
elle a les yeux un feu rouge une blouse
blanche plutôt bariolés elle pèse 270 kg
elle c'est la dernière mode je suis prêt
à partir s'il vous plaît mais très le
passage elle enfin lui jo le robot une
petite merveille de la technologie
américaine capable de se diriger tout
seul dans les couloirs des hôpitaux de
montpellier sa mission apporter d'un
service à un autre les prélèvements les
médicaments ou même le courrier nous
sommes livrés directement dans le
service
avec les quantités évoluent les deux se
voulut ça nous évite des déplacements
quand même cardio cavale pour
l'infirmière un circuit d'environ un
kilomètre répéter 12 heures d'affilée
un personnel moins surmené pour
soi-disant le bien-être du patient droit
de soigner des humains et honnêtement je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
l'utilisation de robots de cet hôpital
ça s'est d'ores et déjà 80 hôpitaux
américains l'ont adoptée à montpellier
et joe suscite encore quelques
interrogations
donc c'est moi sept mois environ parce
que je suis justement j'essaie de faire
des concours de passer les concours pour
a tristement dans le milieu médical et
bcc remplace par des robes à bongouanou
chômage la scpa de trafic sont sûrement
de la direction assure que john est un
outil complémentaire certes mais un
exécutant fiable disponible et peu
coûteux et déjà aux états unis on
prépare un petit frère avec des yeux et
des bras imaginez un socle qui existe
déjà
dans lequel il n'a plus qu'à mettre un
support pour aider la personne chez elle
à mobilité réduite ou invalides de se
lever facilement le matin et de
l'accompagner chez elle en attendant la
visite en chambre avec sourire en acier
trempé
l'hôpital doit encore compter avec ces
bons vieux infirmiers je suis bloqué
s'il vous plaît appelez les techniques
et à l'étranger maintenant il ya ces
arafat et david levy le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères sont
arrivées tout à l'heure à docelles il
s'agit pour eux de sortir le processus
de paix de l'impasse dans lequel il se
trouve depuis la mi mars
depuis qu'israël a décidé d'implanter
une nouvelle colonies juives dans la
partie arabe de jérusalem
c'est un événement aux états unis et pas
seulement pour les mormons
depuis trois mois les adeptes de ce que
certains appellent une secte ont pris la
route comme l'avaient fait leurs
ancêtres il ya 150 ans lors de la ruée
vers l'ouest
leur marche vient de se terminer à salt
lake city
là même où il avait trouvé refuge miles
or ce n'est pas un western ce n'est pas
un film
cet accident deux chariots à quelques
kilomètres de social city et tout ce
qu'il y à de purs
la preuve il y a eu des blessés c'était
terrible j'espère que ça n'arrivera plus
jamais ce fut le seul à cri dans d'un
étrange voyage commencé il ya maintenant
trois mois dans l'ouest des états unis
cinquante deux chariots une dizaine de
voitures à bras et 400 hommes et femmes
en tenues de pionnier ils sont ainsi
parcouru plus de 2000 kilomètres
un convoi pour commémorer la longue
marche de leurs ancêtres
c'était au temps de la ruée vers l'ouest
il y à 1 150 ans john smith fondateur de
l'église mormone venait d'être lynché
vingt mille hommes et femmes prirent la
route et trouvèrent refuge dans le
désert de l'utah
c'est cette épopée que les mormons ont
voulu retracer
ils sont arrivés cet après-midi au bout
de leur voyage
à salt lake city les obsèques du
couturier italien gianni versace tous
ses amis et toutes les stars s'étaient
donné rendez-vous à milan depuis sting
jusqu'à elton john en passant par lady
di naomi campbell et bien sûr jack
franco ferrer l'ancien créateur de dior
toutes ces stars que vous voyez
maintenant à l'antenne du côté de l'
enquête des policiers à miami sont
persuadés que larmes du tueur a déjà été
utilisée par deux fois avant de servir
contre eux monsieur versace c'est une
page pour le moins douloureuse de
l'histoire italienne le tribunal
militaire de rome rendait aujourd'hui
son jugement dans la sphère du massacre
des fosses ardéatines c'est là qu'ont
été exécutés 335 otage par les ss en 44
en représailles d'un attentat organisé
par la résistance italienne
parmi les exécuteurs et riche au pied
que et carl haas ils ont été condamnés
respectivement à quinze et dix ans de
prison mais le tribunal a commué ses
peines et pris que sera libre dans cinq
ans à rome alain choquart sont condamnés
à 10 ans de prison à scarlets et 15 ans
de prison
reid que eric le tribunal militaire de
rome vient de rendre sa sentence
les deux anciens ss sont reconnus
coupables de meurtre répéter aggravé de
cruauté et préméditation
les deux accusés n'étaient pas présents
ils ont boycotté les travaux du tribunal
on a vu presque qu'au début du procès on
sait qu il estimé injustifiées ayant été
absous pour circonstance atténuante
lors d'un précédent jugement autre
tribunal
autre sentence qui est maintenant
considéré comme responsable du principal
massacre nazis en italie pendant la
guerre celui des fosses ardéatines 335
otages civils
dont 75 juif a battu en représailles
après un attentat de la résistance qui
avait fait 35 morts parmi les soldats
allemands
capitaine ss presque était le numéro
deux de la gestapo de rome il vivait
tranquillement depuis la fin de la
guerre en argentine où une équipe de
télévision américaine l'a retrouvé en
1994 date à laquelle il a été extradé
vers l'italie 15 ans de prison réduisent
immédiatement à 5 par le tribunal pour
le massacre de 335 personnes
la peine a semblé un peu légère pour
certaines parties civiles arabes comme
sonny west et jane et l'ema sida à une
personne de cette espèce et pendant 15
ans qui deviennent 5
non vraiment je n'ai pas étudié le droit
mais je suis les affaires de justice et
c'est ce qu'on donne en fait pour un
simple hold up pour quelqu'un qui a fait
un crime de guerre
quinze ans - 10 c'est une farce une
farce italienne en rendant ce verdict
mi-chèvre mi-chou le tribunal militaire
de rome a voulu laver le scandale du
précédent jugement mais il n'a pas été
au bout de sa logique
si vraiment pris que est responsable
d'un crime contre l'humanité alors cinq
ans de prison
c'est tout simplement aberrant
le tour de france ont pensé que cette
16e étape entre morzine et fribourg en
suisse seraient relativement calme il
n'en a rien été
c'est le français christophe mangin qui
l'a emporté au sprint il ya le riche
bien sûr reste en jaune devant richard
virin qu'ils étaient bien sûr de cette
dernière échappée mais l'étape je vous
le disais aura été marquée par de
nombreuses attaques notamment dans le
col de la croix à la principale
difficulté du jour
nombreux sont ceux qui ont donc souffert
dans le peloton à l'image de bjarne riis
qui a perdu trois places au classement
général florent gautreau et alain
poirier
une vraie souffrance une terrible
défaillance bjarne riis a craqué dans le
col de la croix le dernier vainqueur du
tour a perdu plus de 6 minutes après les
terribles étapes alpestres
l'arrivée en suisse a été plus dit
que prévu voilà je n'arrive pas à
comprendre depuis hier ils nous disent
que c'est c'était la dernière étape de
montagne
bon ben on va ressources et graphique
j'ai quand même si ça c'est une étape de
plans joe hickman a c'est peut-être
comme ça que vous regardez celle étape
de plat elle les coureurs craignait
cette étape et ils ont eu raison après
quelques kilomètres seulement le peloton
a explosé
première victime le jeune français david
delrieux qui courre le tour pour la
première fois son rêve de rallier paris
c'est fondent au 30e kilomètre depuis
trois jours il se battait contre une
tendinite tenace mais la douleur et la
fatigue on était plus forte que son
courage c'est le septième abandon dans
l'équipe de la mutuelle de seine et
marne j'espérais toujours ça a un peu
mieux parce que c'est au tour de france
et moi c'est très important et voilà
c'est fini
l' abandon dans le tour c'est le
cauchemar du coureur professionnel
et pourtant certains préfèrent en rire
ce vélo de souffrance rolf ya herman
n'en veut plus il monte dans la voiture
balai le coureur suisse ne connaîtra pas
le bonheur d'arriver sur ses terres un
vélo c'était dur comme prévu
je n'ai pas menti façon un peu souci
c'est quoi tu parles du dur même pour
ceux qui finissent c'est la course à
deux vitesses un chemin de croix
derrière presque me prendre note de
santé devant et on retrouvera bien sûr
le tour de france demain sur sur france
2 voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi dans un instant
la météo de sophie davant qui nous
annonce une dégradation par le seul west
le dernier journal ce sera à florence
dauchez vers l'horreur 50 demain dans
les 4 vérités rémy roche recevra pierre
cardo le d'écumer le député maire de
chanteloup les vignes le 13h avec
laurence piquet et patrick chêne je vous
retrouverai et quant à man à 20h et je
retrouve
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur
france 2